[Music]
what gender am i it's something many
young people are now asking the gender
of my brain doesn't matter the gender of
my biological sex and it's become a
deeply divisive issue divisions even
among the young people receiving
treatment if I couldn't live my life as
a male have the body of male I wanted
don't be around by the age of twenty
thirty I had to stop the train I was
like okay this is a riot what we're
doing here and immense pressure on the
clinicians doing the treating we can't
ever be seen to be a service that can
pronounce with great confidence about
every young person who comes along
nobody can do that
we're exploring the anxieties behind
this debate this is Leo he's sixteen
years old and was born female
he now identifies as male in my school
I'm pretty sure on the only trans person
Lea first came out as transgender at 11
years old he began medical treatment two
years ago taking drugs to pause his
female puberty recently he began
testosterone treatment which does things
like lower his voice and promotes hair
growth when I started you know my
periods that was something that really
it wasn't indicating my parents that
things weren't going to changes when the
phase because that worsened
you know puberty worse and my mental
health worsened my gender dysphoria when
you're transgender it's just different
it's it's excruciating the gender
identity development service that the
Tavistock is where children like Leo
with gender dysphoria are treated on the
NHS that's when the body they're born
with doesn't match their gender identity
skynews research suggests thirty-five
psychologists have resigned from the
children's gender service in London in
the last three years we've managed to
contact 20 of them
only six would speak to us all sexes
said they were concerned about giving
hormone treatment to children with
gender dysphoria all six felt they
weren't able to properly explore
underlying psychological factors looking
back there are young people who I now
wouldn't necessarily put on medication
or sign off on medication this was the
only clinician prepared to be
interviewed they asked us to change
their voice I was once working with an
executive but felt the gender dysphoria
a young person was presenting with it
was really strong really intense so she
decided to put the young person forward
for the hormone blocking treatment after
two appointments looking back it was a
young person with a history of trauma
and direct trauma in terms of abuse and
also there were other things happening
to them and this was not really explored
by the clinician these views were echoed
by others who had worked at the clinic
therapy is not an option in this service
one psychologist told us we fear that we
have had front-row seats to a medical
scandal said another
this is Thomasin she's 19 years old and
was born female she previously
identified as male but D transitioned
earlier this year Thomason lived many of
her teenage years as a boy and was
referred to the Tavistock for treatment
after reading about gender transition
online I thought I didn't meet the
requirements therefore it must not be a
woman I've got at least something else
because I'm not normal mainly the thing
that was feeling me was that it's just
the fact that I didn't fit in and I
didn't know anything and then slowly was
tripped over this idea that you could
change sexes I wanted to have hormones
and be a man have top surgeon be going
down beaches and topless and whatever
else it wasn't living or I felt like
that The Whistleblower says they saw
many female born patients with
underlying issues such as experiences of
homophobia or even a history of abuse
the numbers started growing from 2012
when we started seeing more females
coming forward and this has happened
across a Western world and as a
psychologist did you ever feel that you
could say to a parent I don't believe
your child is trans name and this is one
of the reasons why I decided to leave
the service because as a psychologist I
felt if I ever spoke to a family like
this I would immediately be called
transphobic
they feel scary at times because you're
going down this route of her medical
pipe medicalized pathway and I did have
those little nickels in the back of my
mind I was talking a lot down and I
don't just mean I'm not sure I mean I'm
so confused my head is going to explode
a record number of young people are
being referred to the children's gender
service at the tower stock there were
just 77 patients referred here 10 years
ago by last year the number had climbed
to two thousand five hundred and ninety
children the majority female at Birth
and they've told us around three
thousand more children are on the
waiting list the clinic sees children
under 18 some as young as three years
old around half the children who come
here and put on drugs at puberty -
essentially pulls their physical
development that would be the first step
of any medical intervention the next
would be hormone treatments at 16 years
old and any surgical procedures would
only happen after they turned 18 we came
to speak to senior clinician Bernadette
Wren who told us they fully informed
children about the consequences of
medical intervention in their teenage
years the work that we do to really
inform these young people as fully as we
can what this means to start taking say
testosterone in the example what that
means for them physically what are the
irreversible impacts of that what are
the impacts on fertility what are the
possible to consider the possible
impacts on their sexuality relationships
in the future of the young people who've
perhaps come to us and thought they'd
like to review their decision late and
again one or two they have always said
that they felt we have done everything
that we could to make clear to them the
gravity really of the choice that
they're making I love to talk in depth
about my dysphoria and after that I was
asked questions about my future and if I
were to freeze my eggs stuff like that
which as a 14 year old 15 year old it's
quite difficult to think about and how
did you answer that question
personally my view of it is that I
didn't want to because the process I
thought would have been quite quite
difficult it struggled because I would
have had to go on East region which is
obviously not something I wanted for a
month and then they would have this
process of extracting the eggs
everything and if I wanted kids in the
future which obviously I'm not certain
about but I could always adopt leo only
had to wait seven months to be seen by
the Tavistock but the waiting list is
now two years the psychologist says it's
putting immense pressure on the service
a junior clinician working full time is
expected to carry a caseload of 120 to
130 young people compared to child and
adolescent mental health services
generic services where the equivalent
would be 40 cases at the moment there's
only one pathway through the service is
a medical pathway not a psychological
one but I wasn't aware of this when I
joined the service as an enthusiastic
LGBTQI Ally this is Luke he's 17 years
old and was also born female
he now identifies as male Luke first
came out as trans at 14 years old when
we met he'd been on the waiting list at
the Tavistock for two years since his
referral for treatment it's been an
agonizing wait I was in such a bad place
mentally that I told my mama I can't go
any longer like I'm like in pain and we
were coming out from the GP and I kind
of likes that tearing off and like I
told her like I can't go any longer and
she started tearing up and we both
started crying and she told me that and
if it if it is what I need then we'll go
privately that's was a turning point for
Luke and he set up a phone consultation
with a GP he found online they
prescribed him testosterone which he now
applies as a cream he's essentially
changing his body himself
it's how much of the phone consultation
cost you if I remember correctly maybe
like around 50 pounds I think if you go
for like the Skype call session it's a
bit more expensive but every so often
every so often so they didn't see you in
person
no and they prescribed you testosterone
yes
it's an incredibly dangerous thing to
buy any kind of medicines over the
internet from a supplier of which you
know nothing it's not accredited in any
way we feel really anxious about young
people doing that with or without their
parents consent no one knows exactly how
many children are buying hormones online
and self-medicating
but step-by-step instructions on how to
transition are easily available on the
internet and social media along with
sites selling East Asian and
testosterone
there's no question gender dysphoria is
causing concern and confusion for many
young people and parents but there's a
crisis in the care available a service
overwhelmed with patients and teenagers
trying to bypass the long wait for
treatment for many young people gender
is simply much more fluids children are
being encouraged to express themselves
outside of the binary male/female
stereotypes much of the concern
expressed to us isn't about whether
people should transition or not it's
about the age at which their medicalized
it's become a political and often
fractious debate many of the people who
approached us wanted their identities
protecting for fear of criticism and
almost every expert we spoke to simply
wasn't prepared to comment the Tavistock
say their levels of staff turnover are
not unusual for child and adolescent
mental health services in a statement
they said we have conducted exit
interviews with all departing staff to
understand their motivations and
identify any areas of concern the work
is demanding and the pressures of
operating in a busy service facing a
high level of unfair criticism or
intense kids supports every young person
on a case-by-case basis as an individual
for this generation gender is a big
conversation I am becoming the best
version of myself I'm very happy because
I'm finally becoming myself the fight
for personal identity
now political I don't like this I don't
want to be
a difficult journey for parents as well
as children we were struggling and he
was the one putting his arm around me
and saying it's alright mum I don't
expect you to get it straight work so
yeah
you were very proud of you I am very
proud and experts on the NHS front line
under immense pressure we have a very
long waiting list which complicates
everything about our engagement with
these young people in the help we can
offer them the answer may be different
for each child
but at young ages many are facing big
questions about the body they want for
life